si vous connaissez le sens du mot
jamboree c'est peut-être sans doute que
vous faites partie des deux millions de
français qui sont passés par le
mouvement du scoutisme depuis 1920 date
de la création des scouts par baden
powell un jamboree c'est une grande
réunion comme celle qui se tient en ce
moment à jambville dans les yvelines et
me diras foule
toujours prêt n'est pas tous pareils
les scouts se paie un nouveau look bien
obligé ils ont perdu la moitié de leurs
effectifs en dix ans il n'empêche qu'un
scouts de france 1985 n'est pas très
éloignée d'un scout version baden powell
les créateurs des boy scouts dans les
années 20
alors il une histoire me comprend la
chemise bleue pour les scouts et il ya
un pull beige que j'ai pas sur moi et un
pantalon beige aussi belle aussi les
scouts une organisation paramilitaire
mais non l'uniforme par exemple
s'appelle désormais une tenue et avant
de pouvoir la porter il faut passer par
le parquet de l'intronisation quand on
passe sa promesse au s'engagent à suivre
la loi scoute et la respecter il faut
relever cinq défis il ya eu le défi
d'alliance c'est chez recherché avec
jésus-christ la terre promise
le défi du peuple servir et décider avec
les autres défis de l'homme tenait farol
défi de la lutte exaucé son corps les
scouts de france sont répartis en quatre
groupes
à chaque groupe son projet jouets pour
les plus jeunes laventure jusqu'à 15 ans
entreprendre pour les 14 18 et enfin
l'âge de la route jusqu'à 20 ans bref le
chouette bande de chouettes copains qui
apprennent ensemble à devenir des hommes
alors le projet des scouts de france est
simple c'est un mouvement qui est basée
sur l'action
c'est de permettre à des jeunes d'être
ce qu'ils sont et une permettent une
progression à la fois personnel et une
progression communautaire la progression
personnelle se fait parce qu'un jeune
peut prendre un rôle dans l'équipe dans
laquelle il se trouve et c'est aussi
d'être au service des autres ce qui
permet une protection communautaire à
son bureau des générations entières sont
passés par les scouts dans leur enfance
il faut dire qu'au delà de l'apparence
très structuré le scoutisme nous reste
l'un des moyens privilégiés de contacts
et de dépaysement et s'il est le leader
des mouvements de jeunesse en france
c'est bien aussi parce qu'il est à la
portée de toutes les bourses
la cotisation annuelle est à peine 245
francs